un segundo antes de empezar no os
perdáis los descuentos que están
ofreciendo nuestros amigos de relojes
vincero os dejamos toda la información
por aquí abajo pero ahora vayamos con
nuestro vídeo de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
te hago una pregunta y ya sabes como
siempre que no vale buscar la respuesta
de google linda wikipedia ni en ningún
otro sitio donde dirías que se concentra
el mayor número de obras de arte en todo
el mundo estoy seguro de que la mayoría
de vosotros pensaréis no sé en el museo
británico de londres en el louvre de
parís o tal vez en el moma de nueva york
verdad
pues lo siento pero no vale sí está
claro que todos estos museos albergan
gigantescas colecciones de arte y luego
también tendríamos que definir
exactamente qué consideramos arte y qué
no pero amigos independientemente de
todas estas cuestiones hay un lugar en
el que seguro no habéis reparado y es
que lo cierto es que si queremos dar
respuesta a la pregunta que nos hacíamos
al principio no podemos dejar de tener
en cuenta a ginebra suiza allí vamos a
encontrar un lugar muy especial un lugar
que alberga una de las mayores
colecciones y desde luego la mayor
cantidad de arte por metro cuadrado de
todo el planeta y sabéis que lo más
sorprendente de todo es que ni tú ni yo
lo vamos a poder disfrutar nunca
[Música]
hablamos del puerto libre de ginebras y
si no nos hemos equivocado hablamos de
un puerto en ginebra- que a pesar de no
tener mar es uno de los puertos francos
es decir libres de impuestos más
importantes del mundo para los que no
los conozcáis los puertos libres o
puertos francos son lugares con las
regulaciones más laxas y muchos menos
impuestos la idea es que faciliten el
movimiento de mercancías pero bien el
caso es que fundado en el año 1888 el
puerto libre de ginebras se encuentra
junto a una gran estación de
ferrocarriles que cuenta con un puerto
seco para mercancías y lejos de lo que
podríamos pensar no es de una zona
restringida al paso ni el típico sitio
super vigilado y rodeado de enormes
vallas muros y una gran cantidad de
centinelas lo cierto es que las mayores
colecciones de arte del mundo se
encuentran en un par de edificios no
demasiado grandes que de situarse en tu
ciudad seguramente pasarían de todo
desapercibidos
yo juego porque este depósito cuenta con
tantas obras de arte que ni siquiera los
propios responsables del puerto libre de
ginebra son capaces de cuantificar las
para que os hagáis una idea se calcula
que dentro de sus muros se almacenan
miles y miles decenas de miles de obras
de artistas tan destacados como leonardo
davinci van gogh renoir o el greco entre
otros muchos por ejemplo se cree que son
más de mil y seis mil las obras de
picasso que están depositadas en este
lugar
y es que de hecho tras una auditoría
hecha por funcionarios suizos en el 2012
se reveló que podría haber nada de estar
100% seguros alrededor de 1.200.000
obras de arte
lo que le situaría en el top 3 de las
colecciones mundiales y hablamos de un
auditoría del 2012 se cree que hoy el
inventario final podría ser muy pero que
muy superior amigos para que entendáis
la magnitud de lo que estamos hablando
la national gallery de londres tiene
alrededor de 2300 pinturas en su
colección y el moma de nueva york casi
200.000 obras de arte de diversa índole
yo juego porque no solo estamos hablando
del mayor depósito de arte y no expuesto
de todo el planeta sino que si además
tenemos en cuenta la calidad y el valor
de las obras allí guardadas entonces
este lugar con lo que tiene depositado
en sus almacenes podría constituir el
mejor museo del mundo pero queréis saber
más sobre este desconocido e
impresionante lugar os apetece
sumergidos en un mercado tan desconocido
como es el mercado internacional del
arte pues amigos eso es precisamente de
lo que vamos a hablar en este vídeo así
que vamos a hallar el puerto libre de
ginebra refugio o escondite
seamos sinceros las mercancías y las
cifras que se manejan en el puerto libre
de ginebra son desconocidas ni siquiera
sus propios directores son capaces de
concretarlas
[Música]
pero lo que sí sabemos sobre este
misterioso lugar es que entre cuadros
esculturas y todo tipo de antigüedades y
piezas de arte de lo más variopinto que
el valor de las obras aquí depositadas
es simple y llanamente incalculable eso
y que este espacio se ha convertido en
un buen negocio para el cantón de
ginebra cantón que además de ser
propietario de casi el 90% de las
acciones de este puerto franco ingresa
cada año con su actividad más de 10
millones de dólares pero la pregunta es
por qué los grandes coleccionistas y las
grandes fortunas guardan en este lugar y
no en otros sus colecciones qué ventajas
ofrece estoy seguro que esto es
exactamente lo que muchos os estáis
preguntando llegados a este punto y no
es para menos porque el tema de los
depósitos de arte libres de impuestos es
quizás una de las más desconocidas e
incluso para las actividades comerciales
de algunas zonas francas ahora bien
antes de continuar no penséis que el de
ginebra es el único búnker de arte libre
de impuestos del mundo otro de los más
importantes está cerca del aeropuerto de
singapur y uno de los más recientes en
abrirse está en delaware eeuu es decir
que esto no es ni mucho menos algo
excepcional aunque eso sí el de ginebra
es por goleada el más grande e
importante de todo el mundo
a pesar de que el puerto libre de
ginebra es solo uno de los 10 puertos
libres y 245 zonas francas que existen
en suiza- búnker de arte se ha
convertido en el mayor refugio fiscal
para los grandes gestores de este
mercado una de las principales ventajas
que ofrece es la posibilidad de realizar
transacciones es decir comprar y vender
obras en el propio puerto libre sin
necesidad de pagar ningún impuesto
mientras el bien no abandone el puerto
libre todo lo que se haga con él está
exento de impuestos también está libre
de impuestos el almacenamiento y la
importación de arte hasta el lugar
porque amigos lo cierto es que en la
mayoría de los países se cobran
aranceles o impuestos de entre el 5 y el
15 por ciento a las importaciones de
obras de arte
[Música]
claro que las ventajas fiscales no es lo
único que lleva a los mayores
coleccionistas de arte del mundo a
utilizar ginebra digamos que hay otra
cosa fundamental que tiene también mucho
que ver con la cultura financiera suiza
la discreción el puerto franco de
ginebra es bastante antiguo es un
espacio particularmente que las muros o
pero esto poco importa cuando uno va a
ver una obra de arte sólo necesita una
iluminación decente y la certeza de que
estará bien resguardada el lugar es muy
práctico y céntrico es un sitio seguro
para trabajar y la gente valora la
discreción gyan rennes eye arts director
de ventas del fine art fun group digamos
que aquí siguen la vieja premisa suiza
de no preguntar claro que como os podéis
imaginar eso no es algo que esté exento
de polémica
por ejemplo en 1994 se descubrieron en
el puerto libre de ginebra antigüedades
saqueadas al museo getty de los ángeles
en 1993 se encontraron en este mismo
lugar 200 piezas antiguas robadas egipto
y más recientemente en 2010 se encontró
un sarcófago romano cuya desaparición se
había denunciado en turquía y en 2016
dos sarcófagos etruscos que fueron
devueltos a italia estos y otros
escándalos anteriores obligaron a
realizar reformas para equiparar las
regulaciones a las importaciones que
tienen como destino este puerto libre
con las que se rigen en el resto de
suiza de esta manera ahora los
importadores de obras de arte que llegan
a ginebra deben declarar el nombre del
propietario el origen y el valor de los
bienes que almacenan y desde 2009
también el puerto libre de ginebra debe
contar con un inventario de todos los
bienes que allí se encuentran el
problema muchas por no decir la mayoría
de las piezas que se almacenaron allí
antes del 2009 no han podido ser
inventariadas con lo que sólo sus
propietarios saben que están allí y cuál
es su valor real
[Música]
luego este tipo de lugares tampoco se
libran de las acusaciones sobre el papel
que juegan en el mercado mundial de
blanqueo de dinero
y es que veréis según muchos expertos
resulta relativamente sencillo llegar
con un buen fajo de billetes obtenidos
de forma ilícita comprar un cuadro con
él y revender los meses después para
obtener dinero limpio sin ni siquiera
tener que sacar el cuadro del almacén y
por supuesto mientras no lo vendas pues
tienes el dinero a buen recaudo
evidentemente esto no es el denominador
común y amigos más allá de estas
cuestiones la pregunta que podemos
hacernos 6 estamos ante un refugio o
ante un escondite os dejo la descripción
un vídeo que creo que os puede resultar
interesante sobre esta cuestión
pero llegados a este punto qué tal si le
pegamos un repaso a cómo es y consiste
el mercado internacional del arte porque
hay muchas grandes fortunas invierten su
dinero en obras de arte cuánto dinero
mueve anualmente este mercado cuáles son
los países líderes y emergentes en el
comercio mundial del arte queréis
conocer la respuesta a todas estas
preguntas pues atentos
el mercado del arte un valor seguro
vamos a ver cuando pensamos en un valor
refugio para invertir nuestro dinero en
que pensamos siempre inversiones
inmobiliarias acciones oro pues amigos
para las grandes fortunas el arte juega
también un papel clave y de hecho lo
cierto es que el comercio de arte ha
logrado sortear los embates más duros de
la gran recesión y se ha posicionado
como uno de los activos no financieros
más seguros utilizados por las grandes
fortunas para invertir su dinero
[Música]
de hecho tal y como podéis ver en este
gráfico el flujo de dinero que ha movido
el mercado del arte ha permanecido
bastante estable durante la última
década hablamos de un mercado que cada
año mueve más de 60 mil millones de
dólares
compraventa de obras de arte por cierto
os imagináis cuáles son los países en
los que se concentra fundamentalmente la
actividad de este mercado pues no no se
trata de suizas sino fundamentalmente de
los países eeuu y reino unido- juntos
representan más del 70 por ciento de las
exportaciones mundiales de arte
y si ya lo sé seguro que llegado hasta
aquí muchos os estaréis preguntando vale
vale enrique pero qué significa
realmente todo esto porque el arte es un
valor aparentemente tan cotizado por las
grandes fortunas pues bien pensado en un
momento cada año que pasa el dinero
pierde valor los negocios pueden verse
expuesto a todo tipo de revoluciones
tecnológicas y comerciales y si no que
se lo pregunten a empresas como kodak
blackberry o blockbuster si haces
préstamos puede que te enfrentes a la
morosidad y se invierte su dinero en
renta fija y se produce una crisis y una
ciudad pues tienen muchas papeletas de
perder buena parte de este dinero pero
realmente creéis que algún día se
depreciara el valor de un monet un van
gogh o un picasso creéis que el arte de
firma de artistas reconocidos puede
llegar a perder su valor pues amigos lo
cierto es que hasta la fecha pocos han
sido los casos en los que una obra de
arte famosa se ha vendido a un precio
inferior al de su compra y eso eso es
exactamente lo que anima las grandes
fortunas a crear sus propias colecciones
de arte y es también lo que explica que
se hayan pagado auténticas fortunas por
algunas piezas por ejemplo en 2017
salvator mundi de leonardo da vinci se
vendió en nueva york por la friolera de
50 millones de dólares que si lo habéis
escuchado bien 450 millones de dólares
ojo con los apuntes a diferencia de los
lingotes de oro el mercado del arte es
muy cerrado entre otras cosas porque si
no quieres meter la pata hay que
conocerlo en profundidad y por supuesto
como en cualquier otro mercado se pueden
producir burbujas y la rentabilidad no
está ni mucho menos asegurada sobre todo
cuando se paga mucho por obras de
cuestionable valor o en lo que antonio
garcía villarán denominaría parte
[Aplausos]
en cualquier caso lo cierto es que desde
hace décadas el mercado del arte avanza
con viento a favor expansiones
monetarias tipos de interés por los
suelos de evaluación de monedas etcétera
etcétera echas un vistazo por ejemplo
este gráfico que nos muestra cómo ha
evolucionado el precio de las obras de
arte contemporáneo máscaras vendidas
desde 1989 en 1989 la pieza más cara de
arte contemporáneo se vendió por algo
más de 20 millones de dólares pues bien
la máscara que se vendió el pasado año
2019 una escultura de un conejo de acero
se vendió ni más ni menos que por 91
millones cuatro veces más
pero dicho esto demos un paso más os
imagináis cuál es el país en el que más
ha crecido este mercado durante los
últimos años pues amigos ya os aviso que
no os lo vais a poder creer pero va en
serio estoy hablando de argentina
por volumen de exportaciones de pinturas
y dibujos argentinas ocupa la séptima
plaza en todo el mundo el país del tango
movió 483 5 millones de dólares con esta
actividad comercial en 2010 y 91 atentos
1200 3% más que el año anterior 2018
pero ojo porque si lo comparamos con
2015 el crecimiento ha sido agarras al
asiento de 156 mil 848 por ciento
qué diablos pasa con la argentina porque
el mercado del arte allí está creciendo
como la espuma bien veámoslo
el sorprendente caso de argentina os lo
hemos contado ya un montón de veces aquí
en visual política argentina es por su
burocracia sus regulaciones sus
impuestos y aranceles y un largo
etcétera de restricciones e impedimentos
de toda índole económica todo un
infierno para el comercio la actividad
empresarial sin embargo curiosamente el
caso del arte parece toda una excepción
en esta materia la legislación argentina
se parece mucho e incluso es más libre
que la de muchos países desarrollados
por ejemplo tras la modificación de la
ley 24 633 de circulación internacional
de obras de arte en enero de 2018
argentina flexibilizó aún más los
trámites para exportar e importar obras
de arte ahora tan solo hace falta un
aviso de exportación para obras de
artistas vivos o fallecidos hasta hace
50 años es decir las exportaciones de
arte no están sujetas a licencias ni a
prácticamente ningún control del estado
en un país donde todo absolutamente todo
está regulado de alguna forma
y si además os decimos que este trámite
se puede hacer completamente online la
cosa se pone aún más interesante no
creéis
[Música]
y para aquellas obras de artistas que
fallecieron hace más de 50 años tan solo
hace falta una licencia del ministerio
de cultura una licencia que se consigue
en menos de 48 horas ojalá todo fuera
tan fácil en la argentina sin duda
cambiaría mucho las cosas y les iría
mucho mejor
el caso es que argentina te permite por
ejemplo llegar como turista comprar una
obra de arte y sacarla del país sin
ningún problema como equipaje de mano en
el avión así mismo la ley también
permite mover arte desde el extranjero y
dentro del país sin ninguna limitación
en caso de ferias y exhibiciones sin
necesidad por tanto de realizar lentos
procedimientos burocráticos que cuestan
tiempo y dinero de hecho si hablamos de
arte en muchos campos argentinas
simplemente no parece argentina
[Música]
ahora bien porque este mercado en
particular está tan liberalizado y
desregulado pues bien el argumento
oficial es que se pretende promocionar
la circulación de arte argentino
alrededor del mundo y con ello
fortalecer el mercado nacional del arte
y la protección de nuestras obras de
arte forma parte de algo que todos y
todas tenemos que tener conciencia y
formas que sea algo que quizás no se
visibilicen muchísimo existen existía un
reclamo este sector y nosotros tenemos
que escucharlo como si esta misma
premisa no se puede utilizar para hacer
exactamente lo mismo con el resto de
sectores de la economía no sé por qué
demonios el arte es más importante que
yo que sé la industria de la mermelada y
esto amigos es precisamente lo que
chirría podría estar convirtiéndose
argentina más que en un epicentro
regional para el mercado del arte en
otra cosa un poco más turbia realmente
no es algo que a día de hoy podamos
confirmar al cien por cien pero amigos
las sospechas están sobre la mesa sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta cómo funciona el
resto de la economía argentina pero
llegados hasta aquí turno para ti qué
opinión te merece el mercado del arte
invertiría en él tu dinero
dejadnos nuestra respuesta aquí abajo en
los comentarios y ya sabéis si este
vídeo
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like y suscribir es avisar política
para estar al tanto de todas nuestras
novedades una vez más muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]